et on va démarrer par le grand débrief
du jour retour sur la première de top
chef et hier ça a cartonné un top chef
et ça ils ont un truc de deux singles et
un non mais vraiment vous n'avez vous
pas alors oui cloclo à 8,3 millions est
vrai que c'est très rare pour une saison
12 c'est comme la douzième saison qui
est celle de faire un meilleur démarrage
de relance abaisse de saison en saison
ils ont fait presque trois millions 8
c'est énorme c'est serré croyable
comment expliquer le succès de top chef
nicolas pernikoff bail que les tous les
téléspectateurs reviennent à ce qu'ils
aiment à ce qu'ils connaissent ça les
rassure en ce moment la période est un
peu difficile on voit bien que tous les
démarrages se voice top c'est vrai les
grandes marques l'amour est dans le pré
ont toutes très bien démarré sur top
chef c'est le meilleur démarrage
deuxième troisième numéro redescend
toujours un petit peu et puis le 4e au
monde très fort donc on peut s'attendre
sans doute à l'une des meilleures
saisons de top chef en termes d'audience
je suis un peu d'accord alors si je
devais vous parlez d'un candidat qui m'a
vraiment marqué hier je dirais que c'est
baptiste alors lui oui c'est une immense
d'arc à l'immense rigolade au début on
est tous conscients qu'ils aient le
bonhomme il arriverait sais quoi je sais
tout faire on a gagné deux mois une
omelette norvégienne au moins dos au
boucau je sais faire et après on s'est
rendu compte que c'était une énorme
balle à nos regards et on appelle
baptiste
j'ai 33 ans je suis chef dans un
restaurant dans le sixième de paris le
mot qui me définit le plus ce serait
invincible pitard bonjour moi ça pas
très serein plus stressés ils sont là
ils sont là en vrai et là forcément
c'est plus la même
parce que
j'ai peur un braquage c'est mon petit
mathis exceptionnel grosse grosse
rigolade
alors baptiste je laime beaucoup car il
a voulu préparer un dessert avec ce
qu'il appelle des chiroux café cardamone
connaissiez sao paulo
c'est quoi gré du rallye car la médecine
interne et pis c'est n'est plus ce n'est
pas du tout le cas ce père ou alors en
bas des pistes audio plein boom du plat
mais encore très bien alors ça m'a fait
penser à une chanson que vous connaissez
bien et qu'on adore tous regardé c'est
ça et je vais tenter de surprendre dès
qu'un dessert à base de café cardamone
et ça fait son bac cartes et au café car
damas six dans le caca tnt pisté par la
caf et le café car damas huit ans le cac
a testé par la panne
un petit truc sympathique marché actuel
moi j'adore ta peur d'avoir les restos
sont fermées donc on a juste envie de
dire est qu on a envie de manger on
adore ses chefs
ils sont passionnants on adore les
brigades on adore les brigades et en
plus moi je trouve extérieur parce que
il revisitait des sortes de recettes un
peu classique
le sandwich jambon-beurre lachy
parmentier loire on ce matin chez lé
directeur les poireaux et j'adore
pourquoi pas ce que vous mangez les
poils la barbe du poireau ou la barbe du
pouvoir oui c'est pas la barbe du
poireau n'atteint pas la blanche colombe
hier ils ont aidé chine justement oui
moi je déteste points sans rigoler car
le poids ou alors est ce que vous mangez
le barbu c'est la question qui l'avez
vous faites ce que vous voulez dans vos
souris non mais je te le dis il aurait
monté fait revenir avec un peu de crème
fraîche et à leicester le jouet qui
commencent à quitter pour 7 et 9
le jour alors je le dis aux
téléspectateurs et vieux quand tu t'es
tu le perds ou tu kiffes les câpres tu
t'y faire pareil mais vers le chocolat
noir
il a tout chocolat noir d'accord alors
si toi tu voulais dire sur moi je pense
que honnêtement 60% du succès de
l'émission revient quand même aux 4,4
coach notamment le nouveau paul pairet
honnêtement c'est un raz-de-marée des
téléspectateurs pour lui c'est justifié
il est bien il est bien merci c'est un
était content même si ce matin ils
étaient très contents et et les deux et
les chefs sont vraiment une union entre
qui est phénoménal lui se vannent tout
le temps tout le temps tout le temps et
c'est très agréable pourtant je pense
qu'ils étaient très contents ça ne passe
pas en ce moment donc on avait de l'eau
sur m6 passe à avoir donc trouvé ça très
mou est très long alors non vous avez vu
que castaldi tout
vous attendez de regarder oui alors j'ai
trouvé que le casting était faible et
j'ai trouvé que les quatre membres du
jury n'avait même plus l'air d'y croire
ils sont en train de faire du cabotinage
entre eux je les ai trouvés
et il a coup de gueule tout à l'heure
ouais il a un coup de gueule alors
baptiste je vous le dis c'est mon petit
préféré dire il était en grosse angoisse
et il en a fallu plus il a fallu qu'il
fasse une bafouille qui l'a complètement
discrédité jusqu'à la fin de la saison
baptiste si tu nous regardes bâtisse moi
je te reçois quand tu me dans cette
émission mois témoins héros et si tu
veux venir me faire un osso buco quand
tu veux ici tu es le bienvenu partie
mais les topinambours de les saupoudrer
de cassonade et les maires à l'elysée et
l'écart a misé un peu comme une crème
brûlée brûlé moi je trouve qu'il faut
trop de zèle et qu'ils ont oublié les
fondamentaux du programme ce qu'on a
envie de voir dans top chef c'est des
recettes simples des recettes qu'on peut
faire chez soi
hier il y avait que des recettes
compliquées il y avait un crumble au
curry une rillettes de maquereau au
chocolat blanc défunt des plans en forme
de savon personne peut faire ça chez soi
si ça c'est sur le fond pas non des
rillettes en forme de chat à fédérer y
est en forme de ce nom mais voilà c'est
comme ça parle à personne et sur la
forme faut qu'ils arrêtent avec les voix
off des coachs aparicio baisse qui est
excellent les autres savent pas jouer en
fait ce n'est pas leur métier ça sert à
rien je trouve ça il est dur mais c'est
vrai un programme qui anime oui alors
j'étais déçu pourtant c'est mon émission
préférée nord toutes les émissions alors
là j'étais colère hier comme bon nombre
d'internautes qui ont été ulcérés
pourquoi ça se passe avec les gens on a
basculé sur france 2 déjà qu'ils
allaient partir vous savez pour arrêt
pour parce que sur les deux candidats
ils n'ont pas fait de portraits ils sont
passés à la trappe pas d'interview l'eau
rien sur un sur eux ils ont dû même sous
titré le pot viau et ce qu'il était en
train de dire deux secondes
et hop un tour et puis s'en vont et
c'est eux qui ont été les japonais le
chef lyonnais à will you et qu'est-ce
qui se passe
oui eh bien justement dès le début on a
sus de toutes les lettres éliminé donc
qui avait pas de suspense au pc d'ibm en
a besoin d'un perroquet
pascal a dit mais moi j'ai porté comme
salle alizé
je suis alors d'anciennes d'habitude
c'est des plats de malades préparé par
des gens qui ont pour la plupart
expérience de la gastronomie de haut
niveau mais cette année j'ai
l'impression que les gars ils ont pas
voulu trop trop s'embêter regarde annie
là on commence avec mathieu à les
matches mais je pense que c'est à cette
année bien équilibré
lyall soit la cité
gourmand le côté surprise légumes au
dessert j'ai envie d'y aller en tout cas
j'ai envie de m'amuser avec cette
assiette
j'espère du fond du coeur que ça va leur
plaire et que ça va susciter de
l'intérêt
satisfait dans 7 à 7 philippe autre âge
d'or bonjour en revanche c'est vrai
qu'il ya des fous un mois je leur
reproche que je fais me ne pas pas
particulièrement à l'émission mais la
cuisine en général c'est que le mec
qu'une naissance ingrédients et qui met
15 ans à élaborer un plat avant de le
mettre sur sa carte moi je pense qu'il
faut qu'ils fassent centrale où les
mines mais pas une école de cuisine et
koumassi alors vous avez vu ces souris
tout alors je le dis aux électeurs et
des 19h54 l'émission est en direct on
est obligé de passer par des hommes
ça c'est un truc si on avait été un pur
en enregistrer ça c'est un petit truc
qu'on aurait on ne riez pas vu cette
interface est bien sûr on est obligés
doit pas aller par là et je m'en excuse
auprès des téléspectateurs alors il ya
un candidat qui par guy ressort parmi
les plus détestés c'est mathias marque
alors lui c'est simple il avait le
boulard apparemment je vais pas vous
mentir j'ai pas du tout regardé
l'émission parce que franchement j'adore
la cuisine
j'adore m6 j'adore tout ce qui est top
j'adore qu'est ce que les chefs mais ça
m'en touche une sans faire bouger un
restaurant de jeunes des 27 en finale on
a eu une sophie pic ont élu alain
ducasse on a eu michel portos ce2 et aux
affiches peut-on citer
ben quoi et ça pour nous c'est le feu
pour le challenge et effet pas pour
avoir quatre mille follower en plus
clairement j'en ai rien à [ __ ] r ça va
vraiment venir vous boxez un petit peu
la glotte où le mox est la glotte
c'est l'esprit on est là pour se
dépasser sinon on serait resté sur notre
canapé à regarder les autres va falloir
trouver l'équilibré je pense même
l'harmonie je dirai pas ce que
l'harmonie sasseville équilibre ça se
construit alors surtout si tu dois moi
je vais vous dire pourquoi tant que chef
ça m'intéresse pas du tout parce que je
sais pas cuisiner voilà malheureusement
je ne comprends pas et je comprends les
gens qui aiment mais cherche pas
comprendre que ça faire autant
d'audience
parfois je vais j'arrive j'ai tout le
monde regarde chef des métaux
franchement je suis très content mais
j'arrive pas des sardines et les hommes
étaient faciles à horizon mi temps alors
je pense que les gens ont besoin de
cette émission les aime bien ça peut
cuisiner c'est le retour des gros
programme fort c'est le retour de the
voice et le retour de l'amour dans les
bras
foutez de ma gueule il ya deux minutes
n'ai pas regardé en fait j'ai pas
regardé l'émission j'étais sur mes joues
le parisien
le propose de vous rendre 15 15 minutes
si je peux te donner un conseil demain
quand tu recevras une lettre recommandée
pendant 15 minutes d'émission verdez
ilaha illa ouais ya quelque chose qui
m'a profondément choqué je voulais
partager avec je suis encore c'est un
mec qui lie la fin poireaux et en fait
c'était c'est un tweet du président du
csa monsieur roch olivier maistre un v8
qui dit tout simplement en roulant à
l'écran cher nicolas de tavernost redit
qu à tarnos et le patron de m6 voilà
enfin top chef
ah oui monsieur mais c'est patron du csa
a totalement oublié son devoir de
réserve
donc maintenant je lui demande
aimablement moi qui suis un de ses 4300
abonnés sur twitter
j'aimerais qu'il fasse un tweet vos
bêtises mais ce soir ce serait pas mal
enfin tpm et où l'on aborde les sujets
qui passionnent les français enfin btp
l'émission de référence où l'on parle
politique est directement en prise avec
les gens monsieur roch olivier mais voit
ses origines pacific rock olivier métier
est demeuré tweets enfin gilles verdez
licenciés mais en plus il est sympa de
nouveau patron du csa jeudi
problème ce qui me pose un problème je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec toi moi
j'ai interdit ce genre de tweets
il doit être impartial il était résident
gendarmerie visuel il est européen est
censé parler avec toutes les chaînes
maintenant oui ça et ce qui va se passer
maintenant celle ci va se passer chaque
fois qu'il va y avoir un truc entre le
csa et m6 dans le journal ou ailleurs
marie s'il ya pas une complicité entre
le président du csa m6 c'est vraiment il
doit être impartial donc aucun tweet de
ce genre je ne comprends pas parce que
vous êtes choqués vous tiens je pose aux
téléspectateurs oui je suis pas d'accord
je suis pas d'accord c'est le président
du csa qu'est-ce que ça c'est ce qui
contrôle la télé donc il a le droit dire
qu'une émission
non c'est le gendarme gandar oui c'est
lui par exemple quand il ya eu des
problèmes avec ses pmp remet à la donne
et celui qui était président n'était pas
président non bien sûr mais vous jouez
sur pc sont tous occupent de regarder ce
qui se passe dans le calme ce qui
explique que c'est c'est une règle pas
regarder ce que c'est elle aujourd'hui
c'est celui qui donne des fréquences par
exemple radio détriment des fréquences
un désaccord c'est celui qui régule
c'est celui qui est un champ de
l'audiovisuel lui qui il doit rester tu
dois rester je termine vraiment je
termine doit surtout être impartial ls
qui parle avec tous les patrons de
chaînes et il est pas censé aimer un
programme ou un animateur qui sanctionne
quant à dépassionner oui merci c'est
aussi ça donc ça veut dire qu'il se
passe quelque chose de gaulle et vers
leur hymne à droite sauf que voilà que
pour top chef
il doit le faire pour btp aussi pour eux
je vois pas du tout messieurs c'est
parce que c'est celui qui sanctionne qui
doit pas poster ce genre de tweets
imaginez demain il ya un problème dans
top chef il va pas être crédibles s'ils
le traite de manière trop là est tout
aussi bien on va dire à monsieur vous
poster des tweets à la gloire de top
chef c'est certes tout le monde
non me traite pas tout le monde fuit
jamais de tweet alors vous avez raison
c'est ce que je dis fait manifestement à
titre personnel parce que la mention csa
n'appartiennent n'a pas c'est un
monsieur qui sait un compte certifié
c'est un monsieur qui doit connaître un
minimum les médias dont les médias
sociaux les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui
quand on est patron d'une institution
comme le csa qu'on a un compte certifié
on tweet au nom du csa évidemment ça ça
me parait il ya devoir de réserve et il
ya aussi évoqué mais c'est maladroit ou
soupçon de conflit d'intérêts réunion
sur les statuts cyrille pouget à nantes
j'ai lu les statuts d'accord il a lu les
statuts vecchio au musée oui j'adore
nicolas est ce que tu penses vraiment
que si à des signalements par rapport à
top chef est ce que tu penses que du
coup il va dire ah non non non comme
j'ai twitté il va les protéger
je songe expliqué à mon ressentiez c'est
comme si vous aviez bruno le maire qui
recommençait demain à faire un tweet en
disant ah super génial vincent parlait
de masse en bolloré ou d'un oui l'autre
c'est un autre président entreprises
industrielles il est obligé d'être
impartiale a dit m
ils n ont ils pas mignons une opération
et on va voir ce qu'on pense et
téléspectateurs en tout cas moi je
préfère un patron du csa sa patrie la
témoin qui regardent la télé oui à 60 %
et non à quand vous envoyez ou pas assez
assez assez assez
ouais ça c'est 60% mais bon c'est pas si
crois que ça y est comme ça je préfère
un mec qui regardent avec un droit
d'être content de temps en temps mais
faut qu'il ferait comme ça l'est